a controversial new book about President
Trump's first year in office is on sale
this morning four days early despite a
threat to halt its publication fire and
fury is a sprawling account of political
infighting inside the West Wing of the
White House the book was published early
after the president's legal team sent
cease and desist letters to author
Michael Wolfe the publisher and former
White House chief strategist Steve panic
last night the president slammed abandon
and wolf on Twitter saying in part I
authorized
zero access to the white and white house
for the author of the phony book
look at this guy's past and watch what
happens to him and sloppy Steve the
book's author said he did speak to the
president chip Reid is at the White
House with a copy of the book chip good
morning
well good morning one of the main themes
in this book is the chaotic environment
at the White House as staffers fought
for the president's attention the book
makes clear and as CBS News has
consistently reported the fiercest
battle was between Steve Bannon on one
side and Ivanka Trump the president's
daughter and her husband Jared Kushner
on the other according to the book
mannered Bannon offered Trump a plan to
fire those two and other staffers he
said quote you send those two kids home
you get rid of hope Hicks all those
deadbeats and you'd listen to your legal
team the president did not do that and
chaos ensued as advisers desperately
tried to influence the President and as
competing policies were advanced and
then scrapped Bannon acknowledges that
the president has ignored much of his
advice saying you can't stop him the guy
is going to call his own plays he's
Trump now the White House insists that
this book is full of falsehoods but they
say they're not going to waste their
time going through every one of them
publicly one by one but that is not
keeping the president from raging about
this book on Twitter never a dull moment
thanks chip you bet